team for artificial
intelligence, Jeffrey Hinton
said he resigned to speak more
freely about the technology,
saying it's quickly becoming
smarter than humans.
You left your job at Google
because you want to focus solely
on your concerns about ai.
You've said it could ma nip late
or possibly figure out a way to
kill humans?
How could it kill humans?
>> If it gets to be much
smarter, it will gain
manipulation because it will
have learned that from us.
So it would be a more
intelligent thing being
controlled by a less intelligent
thing.
It can figure out ways of
manipulating people to do what
it wants.
>> What do we need to do, pull
the plug, put in far more
restrictions and back stops on
this?
How do we solve this problem?
>> It's not clear to me that we
can solve this problem.
I believe we should put a big
effort into thinking about ways
to solve the problem.
I don't have a solution
presently.
I just want people to be aware
that this is a really serious
problem and we need to be
thinking about it very hard.
I don't think we can stop the
progress.
I didn't stein the petition
saying we should stop working on
ai because if people stopped in
mesh, people in China wouldn't.
It's very hard to verify if
people have been doing it.
>> There have been
whistle-blowers warning about
the dangers of ai.
One was forced out of Google for
voicing his concerns.
Looking back, do you wish you
had stood behind these whistle
blowers more?
>> That's actually a woman.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> So they were rather different
concerns from mine.
I think it's easier to voice
concerns if you leave the
company first.
D idea is they'll get more
intelligent and take us over.
>> Steve Wozniak, to co-founder
of apple, is also speaking out
about the dangers of ai.
>> Ai is another more powerful
tool and it will be used by
those people, you know, for
basically really evil purposes.
And I hate to see technology
being used that way.
It shouldn't be, and some --
probably some types of
regulation are needed.
>> It sounds like you agree.
>> I agree with that, yes.
>> What should that regulation
look like?
>> I'm not often expert on how
to do regulation.
I'm just a scientist who
suddenly realized these things
are getting smarter than us.
I want to blow the whistle and
say we should worry seriously
about how we stop these things
getting control over us.
And it's going to be very hard.
And I don't have the solutions.
I wish I did.
>> Does there need to be a
meeting of all of the tech
groups and governments working
on this, Google, China,
whatever, in some sort of set of
rules of the road?
How do we've pardon text against
bad actors or rogue nations
harnessing ai?
>> So, for some things it's very
hard like using ai for
manipulating electrics or for
soldiers but for the existential
threats taking over, we're all
in the same boat.
It's bad for all of us.
So we might be able to get China
and the U.S. To agree on things
like that.
It's like nuclear weapons.
If there's a nuclear war, we all
lose, and it's the same if these
things take over.
So since we're all in the same
boat, we should be able to get
agreement between China and the
U.S. On things like that.
>> Do you think tech companies
will be the solution or are they
so invested in this financially
and also, let's be frank, in
terms of power, that they're not
going to be part of the solution
here?
>> I think the tech companies
are the people most likely to be
able to see how to keep this